40% c'est la part que représentent les
vins bio dans ce rayon de producteurs
locaux entre conversion des fournisseurs
historiques et arriver des jeunes
vignerons écolo les labels verts sont de
plus en plus présents en grandes
surfaces une agriculture raisonnée qui
est dans les tuyaux depuis de nombreuses
années mais qui se concrétise par le bio
aujourd'hui
et une demande de nos clients
certainement de qui qui souhaitent avoir
des produits plus sains
oui alors moi le 26 et au moins 40% des
ventes mais j'ai toujours au moins un
domaine en bio chaque appellation de
touraine
installé à tour depuis 2010 ce caviste
fait le même constat si les vins
d'agriculture biologique ont toujours eu
leur place sur ses étagères il observe
un réel engouement pour ce type de
production c'est vrai qu'il ya de plus
en plus de demandes des clients en vins
bio et une méfiance de moins en moins
grande par rapport à ces 20 la part
rapport réalisant
une méfiance moins importante grâce à
une meilleure connaissance de cette
pratique autrefois considérée comme une
simple tendance marketing la place aux
chinois pas mal de succès dans sa
culture biologique parce que nous avons
des millions mais ça je le pense
vraiment qu'on a envie de bien faire qui
sont courageux qui maîtrise totalement
et avec une dynamique de jeunes
vignerons qui reprennent d'ailleurs déjà
ancien d'une gaine vrai une vraie
volonté de bien faire si les vins
biologiques du val de loire constitue
toujours un marché de niche leur vente
en supermarché a augmenté de 51% depuis